eric zemmour dit je ne suis pas raciste
je crains hélas que vous soyez un peu le
monsieur jourdain du racisme et que vous
soyez raciste sans le savoir vous avez
demandé qu'on vérifie le sens des mots
l'étymologie est très bien le racisme
d'après le robert puisque vous même vous
avez voulu rappeler une définition c'est
l'idéologie qui postule à une hiérarchie
des races ou à une hostilité
systématique contre un groupe social le
racisme celui qui croit à la hiérarchie
des races qui est costil hostile à des
groupes ethniques considérés comme
inférieurs ou dangereux or vous même
vous croyez aux races même si vous dit
que vous venez de lire la comment parce
que vous venez de lire une différence
biologique des races avec sky j'ai pas
lu biologie venait d'inventer vous
croyez vous qu'il y aura cet industriel
dit non non attendez vous avez dit
aujourd'hui des races n'existent plus ça
vous arrange bien parce que vous avez
raison des races n'existent pas
simplement vous êtes l'un des seuls
aujourd'hui à l'ignorer puisque vous
l'avez revendiquer à plusieurs reprises
les races pour vous existe vous croyez
par ailleurs aux différences de comment
dirais-je de valeurs entre les cultures
vous l'avez dit vous l'avais répété vous
l'avez écrit vous considérez que la
culture occidentale par exemple est bien
supérieur à des cultures africaines
millénaire je pense à répondre à tout ça
bien sûr d'accord mais sur vous pour
répondre évidemment dont vous voyez vous
répondez tout à fait vous croyez la
hiérarchie des races huras à la
hiérarchie est par ailleurs la
stigmatisation d'un groupe vous avez
beau le nier
avec sourire parce que c'est l'une de
vos forces c'est d'essayer on est reçue
il sourire et à s'intéresser de mètres
du sol et dans les horreurs que vous
racontez
les
sourires dans legacy ce que vous
racontez dans la question n'est pas
seulement celle de la ceni à la question
vous devez pas entendu
mais c'est normal quand on est obsédé
par soi même le bonheur là bah oui
attention ton mec vous en tête je ne
fais jamais de fabrique pas ce qu'on va
devoir faire le décompte donc à l'isi
non mais je vais terminer pas entendu
inédit quelque chose de drôle paramo
j'aurais voulu savoir ce que c'était et
ensuite pour faire les musulmans je vous
laisse et répondent bien évidemment il
s'agit pas simplement la question de
l'élimination vous passez votre temps à
les insulter à les insulter à les
dénigrer
lorsque vous écrivez par exemple que
tous les musulmans qui le disent ou pas
considère les djihadistes comme des bons
musulmans quand vous n'étiez encore à
l'instant que les musulmans
appartiennent à une religion totalitaire
ce s'appelle tout simplement la
stigmatisation d'un groupe un groupe
religieux en l'occurrence bon eric alors
on va on va lancer le dé content parce
que oui parce que la leur il ya déjà on
peut déjà faire l'émission l'australien
ben problème c'est qu avez-vous
évidemment le racisme les migrations
s'est quasiment votino allait diriger
les voyons bah voyons bah oui
d'abord voyons un petit ben voyons on va
les compter ce soir abbaoui gallet vous
savez quand vous savez pas quoi dire il
ya le petit ben voyons non écoutez aller
la laïcité le meilleur du temps s'il
vous plaît à les rapporter à leur parler
comme ça ok je vous parle comme je veux
un nom n'est pas encore président et
quand bien même vous le sauriez je vous
parle je veux opm rit pas agresser les
six répondu à eric zemmour sinon on est
on est dans le débat il faut qu'on ait
des faucons énormément je répète le
racisme c'est faire des différences
biologiques vous l'avez dit vous-même
pas avec des races qui sont supérieures
aux veaux je ne crois absolument pas en
cela vous croyez plus off vous savez on
m'accueille encore rares mais ils n'ont
témoin écoutez moi n'ont répondu à ma
question je ne sais ce que je verrai
encore je verrai à vos réponses et
pensent des rats si vous me laissez par
les gones interprétera s'en faut mais si
je voulais vraiment de questions et si
on est ce qu il est rasé honte et je
leur répondais menaçant d'orage et le
concept massot grâce au 19e siècle et
c'est un concept scientifique et les
scientifiques à l'époque c'étaient des
progressistes comme vous qui voulait
justement à battre le concept d'humanité
né du christianisme vous voyez on va
quand vous allez encore noyé le poisson
moi c'est juste vous croyez aux rasses
oui le nom olalala répondez-lui eric
mais je lui ai laissé mon nom vous
croyez brasse coulée il y à il y a
bakondi a des couilles petite fille qu
il ya des jours où il ya des groupes à
bien vous les appelez comme vous voulez
il y a des goûts vous les appelez comme
vous voulez encore ce que je vais vous
dire c'est que c'est c'est une combe
s'ils ont le moral si vous voulez pas
comprendre ça donc on peut vous tapez
groupes ethniques des choses tout de
suite dans votre bouche et
c'est pas alors s'il vous plaît
j'aimerais qu'on parle du sujet
immigration que faut-il changer je
voudrais répondre parce qu'il n'a pas
les lire et comme ça donc ce que je
voulais vous dire c'est que le racisme
je vous ai dit maintenant quand vous
dites j'insulte les musulmans je
n'insulte jamais les mesures
américaines rick perry qui se sont
insultés chouly ouais je vous le dis
sont insultés grands pas tous si la
plupart n'ont alors pas répondait mais
quand si vous voulez je considère que
vous savez il y avait le communisme n'a
guère le communisme on disait que
c'était une religion séculière et on
disait que c'était une religion
totalitaire vraiment aaron disait
religion totalitaire les communistes
pouvait s'estimer légitimement insultés
et ben c'est la même chose je considère
que l'islam est une religion totalitaire
jaune dessus d'ailleurs pas le seul à le
dire vous savez ernest renan disait que
c'est l'union indiscernable du spirituel
et du temporel
c'est le règne d'un dogme ce sont les
plus lourdes chaînes qu'on que
l'humanité ait jamais porté je passe
donc donc un restaurant et lui aussi
raciste très bien donc que je continue
ma mère délurée qu'on a reçu jusqu'à
maintenant défense mais c'est vous qui
avez commencé je vous ai pas dit oui
mais faire une virée en bulles monopole
à l'est tout autant le sur dix minutes
sur une
réplique on va parler d'immigration du
joyel fois les loyers répondez moi j'ai
respecté votre question tout respectueux
et marées si vous faites comme son
épouse et un intervenant forcément fait
oui je ferai comme je voudrais vous
plaît allez donc je dirais je
rajouterais que défendre sa culture
considérer qu'elle est supérieure ça ne
veut pas dire ceux considérés comme
supérieurs ça veut dire la préférée à
celle des autres d'accord vous vous
détestez vous le culture vous détestez
d'où vous venez c'est pas mon cas moi
j'aime la culture française je l'admets
je l'admiré jeu là d'autres que vous
connaissez aussi mal que vous connaissez
les musulmans s'il vous plaît